and today's my last class and so in this
presentation we hope to
discuss and pull together a lot of
different themes that we've talked about
over the course of the semester namely
centered around discourses of power so
we've kind of teased apart the idea that
there are political economic social and
linguistic discourses of power that
impacts the way people live their lives
and how they identify and hopefully by
learning about these different
discourses of power we can find the
treasure trove all right understanding
identity so in terms of discourses of
power in the political sense in our
readings about different nations in the
Caribbean we discussed the general topic
was colonialization as a discourse of
power and how colonialization in all of
these countries established dominant
discourses for racial social linguistic
econ and economic hierarchies of power
we and how these hierarchies kind of
dictated the structure of the society so
the government the governmental power
went to a small group of elites that
were kind of reminiscent of the Cologne
of the way the colonies were set up and
then even after colonial power was left
these colonies these new nations were
still set up in this structure of
colonial power with the dominant
hierarchies remaining unchanging race
social linguistic and economic so we've
talked a lot this semester about the
idea of phibian exceptionalism nation of
capsular genome but last last week we
kind of also touched on the idea that
this like neo-colonial power political
aspect is something that's pervasive the
worldwide in post-colonial states like
Rachel said in maintaining colonial
power hierarchies even after
independence personally speaking India
is an example of this people from upper
castes and like Hindi speaking pop
relations within India under British
colonial rule tended to be given a lot
of power and that is very much how India
is structured today
also within the diaspora even like
non-political in terms of legislation a
lot of the South Asian Diaspora
is centered around Hindi speaking upper
caste experiences so then there's also
the idea of economic discourses the
power that political power kind of also
confers economic power on a small group
of elite people this limits access to a
lot of resources and global capital and
further helps in keeping people in
post-colonial stratified societies in
the Caribbean you can look at trade and
how in equal balance of trade kind of
support more importing than exporting
which is very damaging and so globally
these dominant discourses of economic
power are have a parallel throughout the
world in terms of the distribution of
economic capital and the allocation of
funding of global funding and so
specifically certain countries tend to
have control over valuable resources
even if they're not necessarily located
within their own countries an example of
that is us hand in oil and the Middle
East at some point in history and
currently and then the idea of
international aid being focused on
certain countries based on natural
disasters and such I mean also if we
look like like two months ago there was
a conference held in California the
African global economic and development
summit that's meant to help like bridge
ties between businesses in the US and
Africa and lead to economic development
but none of the delegates from African
countries were able to even enter the
u.s. to attend the summit because of
visa difficulties so we had like
discussions
Africa's economic and developmental
future being held like Professor de
Graaff was saying but no one who really
had personal stake in Africa so these
economic and political discourse of
power also contribute to socially
stratified societies where social
mobility is challenged so education is
usually seen as a means for social
mobility and subverting the
stratification
but in a lot of cases like we've
discussed previously education and
access to education is also stratified
and it's very an equal we've talked
about linguistics and like language
being a barrier to accessing education
within the Caribbean with French based
education in Haiti and the work of MIT
Haiti to try and change this but
education is also barred by political
and natural disaster issues and the idea
that this in equal access to education
further cements stratification globally
there are parallels of this
stratification throughout contracts and
so the idea of cultural capital and
different countries cultures being more
valuable than others
has kind of created this idea of like
ultimate cultures to aspire to and it's
create it's attributed to it's
contributed to the idea of cultural
assimilation which is happening in such
a global like as our society becomes
more and more global and there's a lot
of migration and there are more correct
cultures and more indirect cultures and
the same with language and so if we've
seen like situations of this cultural
assimilation in the US with in it
throughout history and throughout the
world but specifically in the u.s.
thinking about school the boarding
schools for the Native American
where they were forced to well they
where they were punished for speaking
their native languages or participating
in their native culture even amongst
themselves and not in an educational
setting and parallels in countries like
Haiti and Jamaica where they were not
when they went to school that at some
point they were not allowed to speak
their Creoles so their native languages
personally the thing that comes to mind
in terms of cultural assimilation is in
the small town where I went to high
school specifically at the high school
there were three acceptable cultures or
like did well-defined cultures it's like
being a white American being a black
American or being Hispanic and within
Hispanic they meant specifically Mexican
not really being either Hispanic Mexican
or white being a white Hispanic and not
Mexican it was kind of interesting to
resist cultural assimilation of like
choosing one or the other especially
when people would tell me things like
speak English because we're in the u.s.
to which I think are especially
responded in Spanish much to their
irritation but it just like having to
choose between having friends and losing
my culture often I chose just to be with
my family because I was more important
to me but that pressure was definitely
present definitely also someone who's
first gen the idea of assimilation
something that's had an impact on my
life and for me it's really been really
interesting to kind of tease apart the
differences an attitude sort of
simulation between like my generation
and my parents generation because my
parents are the ones that moved to the
US and for them assimilation was
something that they they didn't teach me
their languages and for people with
their generation we have family friends
that seek to assimilate kind of by not
only adopting Western American styles
address and language but also by
forcibly distancing themselves from
their South Asian
even if they are born and raised in
India like there's a family friend that
refuses to fly certain airlines to
certain places in the world to not be
seen as part of that South Asian crowd
and and things like that versus like
people my generation where it's been
come kind of a reclamation if identity a
kind of like like Rachel was talking
about kind of a trying to avoid
assimilation by by adopting different
styles of dress and sort of reclaiming
your heritage but it's also interesting
to compare assimilation and attitudes
towards like a solution towards a
melting pot versus in the US versus in
the Caribbean people tend to call the
u.s. a melting pot but there's
definitely still like stratified social
groups and cultural groups within the US
versus in an almost as if you're trying
to aspire to one assimilated one
American norm whatever that means even
though we're supposed to celebrate our
cultural diversity but the Caribbean as
the Walcott reading pointed out like so
beautifully I thought that there are so
many different points and lingering like
memories of vestiges of different
cultures within the Caribbean they all
exist harmonious lis and create a new
culture so the idea of like is the u.s.
truly a melting pot or are there better
examples of that in the world ok and
then so we've been hinting around it
basically a political economic and
social discourses of power also confer
into linguistic discourses of power
there's the quote from oh and it was
very wonderfully captured in the several
of the readings the quote from the
Bishop of City to the Queen of Spain
when Columbus requested to like go into
the colonies he like handed her a
dictionary of Spanish and was like
language is the perfect instrument of
empire and I thought that was very like
representative of how like social
political and economic kind of fed into
linguistic discourses of power as the
like predominant vehicle for it and
today with in the Caribbean s we've just
this this plays out in education in the
language of education in the language of
politics in the language of the upper
class where the lake the native language
a very very small population is given so
much precedence over the language the
lingua franca of these countries and a
language that is very unlimited of these
countries itself it's a language that is
a melting pot creole is a language that
is born of so many different languages
coming together just as Caribbean
culture is born of so many different
peoples coming together and it's a bit
ironic there's a Libyan quote that says
to take away someone's access to their
mother tongue is to also take away
access to their best tool for social
change essentially and a lot of the
readings hinted at this that reclaiming
language through music
like what Coke was doing in Jamaica
through poetry like what Chamberlain was
suggesting is a way of subverting these
economic and political discourses of
power and these discourses of linguistic
power are paralleled globally as I'll
have all a bit different English
discourses so far we've been talking
about in to prevailing ideas that are
linked together the idea of
prescriptivism which feeds into cultural
capital that there is a correct way of
speaking every language and then there
are predominant correct languages and
incorrect languages are better than
worse and this has been a larger larger
form of goal global control of language
and it contributes to the ideas
linguistic genocide which has now been
documented very well that it's rampant
throughout the world that languages are
dying at alarming rates but it's it's
linked to this idea that there is a
correct language and that and the
speakers of these quote-unquote
incorrect languages have abandoned for
violent and nonviolent reasons and so
like this idea is has been a very big
lunch
so they're now talking about how all of
these predominant discourses of power
impact the shaping and formation of
identity so there are a lot of conflicts
in defining identity in post-colonial
world the idea so Barack Obama has a
quote that the worst thing that
colonialism did was to cloud our view of
the past but also this view of the past
is kind of something that a lot of
countries are struggling with when
defining today's identity is what is our
relationship to the past was a
relationship to colonial powers to
countries that the people of today come
from and how do we or do we at all
use these influences to shape a unique
national identity today if we look at
Jamaica their way of shaping and unique
Jamaican identity was through their
music through what Coke was doing and in
in sponsoring these dancehall music the
popularity of it and through the
propagation of Caribbean poetry and just
the idea that language can be used as a
tool to create a sense of and maintain a
sense of identity and then identity also
has kind of a dual nature and that goes
along with this like choosing whether or
not we are colonial or not or both or a
new thing is that identity is both self
chosen and imposed and you can choose
how all of these discourses of power
influence how you define yourself and so
then like the idea as well-cut said yeah
he he kind of hinted at the idea that
historically Caribbean cultures have
struggled or people have struggled with
the idea of identifying Caribbean
cultures as being a culture people
because they're so hodgepodge and made
up of so many different influences kind
of harkening back to idea like purity
and authenticity and so like using this
idea of purity as a way of
citing weather like what you choose are
what's imposed on you makes you pure or
not and how you decide to identify with
that idea and whether or not it's
authentic to have chosen or to be
imposed and like what remains in your
identity in terms of the idea of
authenticity that funeral and at je vais
discuss and their paper that we read
you